Bitte schön.
Guten Tag. Ich heiße Saarjit Coach und bin aus der Sonstanz.
Ich bin aus der Sonstanz.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einpeilstand?
Ja, bin ich.
Wie heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Peter Bornehmann.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen nach Samu Stabieren?
Ja, Bornehmann schreibt sich
E M A N N
Bornehmann.
Herr Bornehmann, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 61.
61?
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 7. August 1963.
63?
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,86 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie das für das Zeit?
95 kg.
Danke schön, Herr Bornehmann.
Was für ein solches Auto?
Ich habe ungefähr 3 Stunden sehr starke Kopfschmerzen.
3 Stunden.
Ja, seit 3 Stunden.
Ich habe noch nie starke Kopfschmerzen gehabt.
Zum ersten Mal haben Sie Kopfschmerzen.
Ich habe schon mal Kopfschmerzen gehabt,
aber nicht so stark.
Wie ist das jetzt?
Die haben relativ schnell bekommen.
Wo genau sind diese Kopfschmerzen?
Im ganzen Kopf.
Das ist so drückend, als wenn der Kopf zerspringen will.
Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen näher beschreiben?
Sind sie pulsierend, bohren?
Mehr so drückend, dumpf.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einem Skalopon 1 bis 10,
wobei ein sehr leichter, sehr starker Schmerz in den Spiegel liegt?
7 bis 8.
Herr Bornehmann,
können Sie diese Schmerzen an der Wand oder manchmal?
Jetzt seit 3 Stunden an der Wand.
Die Schmerzen haben auch derzeit schon immer geworden.
Nicht wesentlich.
Sie sind gleich ziemlich stark angefangen.
Haben diese Schmerzen in einer Körperregion ausgesprochen?
Beispiel in den Macken?
Nein.
Gibt es etwas Trosteschmerzen, Lindar oder Taschtakt?
Beispiel, wenn Sie sich, also wenn Sie den Kopf neigen?
Am besten, wenn ich alles so, also ob der Kopf zerspringen will,
wenn ich die Hände so halte
und die ganze Zeit die Hände gehalten zu Hause,
und ruhig gesessen.
Ruhig gesessen, also wenn Sie, zum Beispiel im Dunkelrum,
also im Dunkelraum,
wenn Sie sich das nicht verbrauchen,
ist das nicht unbedingt, glaube ich nicht.
Okay,
ist Ihnen übel, haben Sie Erbrocken?
Ja, ja, mir ist ziemlich übel,
ich habe 2,
und ich habe auch starken Schwindel.
Und Schwindel, wie sah das Erbrocken aus?
Ja, so schleimig, gelblich.
Schleimig, gelblich.
Haben Sie Brutchipurin, Brutfäden,
immer Brockenen bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie das Erbrockenen mit dem Essenrestaurant?
Ich habe sie vor 3, 4 Stunden, habe ich befrühstückt.
Da waren vielleicht noch etwas,
so Speichern,
aber nicht viel.
Hauptsache, das verschlein ich.
Also vor wegen der Kopfschmessen haben Sie
nicht Brütze oder
Geräusche bemerkt?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie sehr Störungen?
Sehen Sie durch die Brut?
Nein, ich habe sie nicht bemerkt.
Ich sehe nicht so scharf.
Doch beim Lesen, das fällt mir schwer.
Also das ist nicht gut.
Das Sehen ist eingeschränkt.
Seit 3 Stunden?
Seitdem die Schmerzen da sind.
Seitdem die Schmerzen angefangen haben.
Okay.
Herr Börnermann,
Sie haben die Schmerzen gemacht.
verspüren Sie Tapeweißgefühlkribben auf einer Körperseite?
Nein.
Haben Sie Kraftminderung
in den Armen oder in den Beinen?
Glaube ich nicht.
Wobei ich gehe kaum, weil mir so Schwindliches.
Da habe ich das nicht so ausprobiert.
Aber ich glaube nicht.
Sie haben mir gesagt, Sie haben früher ähnliche,
leichte Kopfschmerzen.
Aber die habe ich selten.
Ich habe vielleicht zu alle 3-4 Wochen
etwas Kopfschmerzen.
Leicht, dreivier Wochen habe ich mal Kopfschmerzen.
Also ungefähr 10-12 Mal im Jahr habe ich Kopfschmerzen.
Aber die sind nicht so schlimm gewesen.
Das war alles in Ordnung.
Das ging nach einigen Stunden wieder weg.
Die sind in einigen Stunden
früher diese Kopfschmerzen gegangen.
Aber diese Kopfschmerzen sind
kein Vergleich mit diesen Kopfschmerzen heute.
Heute sind die so stark
und mit Schwindel und Übelkeit.
Ich musste vorher nie übelkeit.
Das ist ein ganz anderer Kopfschmerz,
als ich in sonstigen Stunden.
Das sind so Kopfschmerzen,
wie aus dem heiteren Himmel.
Das ist relativ schnell.
Das sind so Kopfschmerzen,
wie aus den 3 Tagen,
wenige Stunden oder so?
Wenige Stunden.
Die sind ganz anders vom Charakter her.
Während dieser Kopfschmerzen.
Also die Träneren sind augengerötet.
Also die Nasel läuft.
Nein.
Schwitz sind auf einer Seite des Gesichts.
Nur Übelkeit ist begleitet momentan.
Heute, jetzt habe ich starke Übelkeit.
Ich habe sonst noch nie gehabt.
Ich habe sonst nie Übelkeit gebrochen beim Kopfschmerzen.
Und andere Selbstständige haben sie nicht.
Ich habe grünen Starr und nehme da Medikamente vereint.
Da werde ich immer kontrolliert beim Augenarzt.
Der misst den Augendruck.
Zuletzt war er aber ganz gut.
Er war in der oberen Grenze, aber der Augenarzt war zufrieden.
Also, wer suchen Sie regelmäßig wegen dieser uräne Starr,
Ihren Arzt?
Augenarzt, einmal im Jahr.
Einmal im Jahr.
Ich habe mich zu Kontrolle.
Er sagt mir, wenn ich Räume hab,
wie ich zur Kontrolle und er sagt mir, wenn ich sonst etwas habe, muss ich mich melden, aber im Jahr gehe ich zur Kontrolle.
Was verwenden Sie? Astrophon?
Timoptol.
Also verwenden Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf?
Zweimal pro Tag.
Und Sie verwenden regelmäßig?
Heute tropfen wir heute.
Jedes auch.
Okay.
Und zu...
Herr Bonemann.
Sie haben gesagt, sie haben, also sie verarspeln können,
kreben, tarfarben, gefühlen oder kraftminderung.
Und zu begleiteten Überkalt.
Und sie haben zweimal Erbrochen und Schwindeln.
Sie haben einen innernisten Momentan schwindelt.
Sie sehen die Verschwemmen.
Also, Pro Monat, also wie oft verschwürfen Sie diese Kopfschmerzen?
Pro Monat?
Also circa einmal pro Monat, aber wie gesagt, es sind andere Kopfschmerzen, die ich sonst habe.
Wie kann man nicht vergleichen?
Mir ist dann nicht übel.
Ich habe keinen Erbrechen.
Sie sind längst nicht so stark die Kopfschmerzen.
Das ist für mich harmlos.
Jetzt sind die Kopfschmerzen...
Wenn Sie mit dem Schmerz sind, bezüglich des Glaukoms,
sind diese Schmerzen nicht gleich auf.
Nein.
Wegen dieser grüneren Stein, ich meine.
Okay.
Ich würde jetzt ein paar Fragen zu Ihren allgemeinen Zustand stellen.
Herr Bonemann, haben Sie Luftnot, Atemnot?
Nein.
Sie haben Luftnot?
Nein, ich habe nicht Luftnot.
Aber Sie haben Luftnot, Atemnot, Atemnot?
Ich habe es nicht bemerkt.
Ich war bisher auch nirgendwo bekannt.
Ja, ob die Probleme beim Wasser lassen sind oder im Luftwurz?
Der Urgang ist in Ordnung.
Da habe ich eine Vorsorge der Anspiegnung gehabt vor einem Jahr.
Das war gut.
Wasser lassen muss ich manchmal zweimal in der Nacht Wasser lassen.
Aber kann danach wieder gut schlafen, das stört mich nicht.
Seit wann zweimal nachts Wasser lassen?
Ja, seit fünf Jahren ungefähr.
Ich war beim Urologen.
Der Urologer sagt, die Prostata ist leicht vergrößert.
Wenn ich aber sonst, wenn mich das nicht weiter stört,
er möchte das so kontrollieren.
Aber zurzeit keine Tabletten.
Momentan nehmen Sie keine Tabletten gegen die Prostata.
Sie haben keinen Duschmann.
Sie sind verstopft.
Haben Sie viel?
Ich glaube nicht.
Und spülen Sie sich nicht viel an?
Nein.
Sie wissen Sie nachts in der nächsten Seite mehr?
Nicht auffällig.
Aber Sie in der nächsten Seite mehr?
Nein.
Ich habe mein Gericht behalten.
Erwohnen Sie Probleme einzuschlafen?
Das himt von meiner Schicht ab, wenn ich arbeite.
Wenn ich Spätschicht habe,
dann komme ich oft erst um halb zwölf, nachts nach Hause, abends.
Dann kann ich nicht wieder einschlafen.
Wenn ich Frühschicht habe, dann kann ich nicht wieder einschlafen.
Ich habe keine Schicht,
dann kann ich nicht wieder einschlafen.
Wenn ich Frühschicht habe, dann muss ich manchmal um 5 Uhr anfangen.
Dann ist der Schlafen auch nicht so gut.
Aber es ist für mich kein Problem.
Nur während dieser Nachtschichten haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen?
Ja, ich habe nicht Nachtschicht.
Ich arbeite entweder bis abends um halb elf, elf.
Abends spät schicht ich meine.
Ja, dann bin ich um 10 oder halb zwölf zu Hause.
Aber sie haben es nicht leichter zu werden.
Herr Wohnlomann, danke für die Ausgabe von der Corona-Krise.
Wie steht die Greekostrom der Von Taiwan?
Ich habe hohe Blutdruck vor 10 Jahren.
Da nehme ich auch Medikamente ein,
und ich habe hohe Scholesterien auch seit 10 Jahren.
Da nehme ich auch Medikamente.
Ich habe zu Hause Vertrage der Milchzucker
Mädchzucker nicht so gut, das habe ich gemerkt, da habe ich Brechschmerzen bekommen, manchmal
einen Durchfall, aber das habe ich im Griff, weil ich mich dementsprechend dann erwehre.
Es geht.
Seit wann leiden Sie an Grüne Stadt?
Ja, auch so seit drei, vier Jahren.
Drei Jahre.
Drei, vier Jahre.
Haben Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen außer dieser Erwärmung vor Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich hatte Geilenprobleme, Geilensteiner und Koliken und da wurde ich an der Geilenblase operiert.
Wie wurde diese Operation erfolgt, laphorospopisch, mit Dampfschaerobien?
Ja, in Knopfloch, Knopflochschärobien, drei Schnitte mit Röhren in den Bauch, also kein großer Schnitt.
Nur drei oder vier, vier Bauchsschnitte.
Auf jeden Fall kein großer Schnitt.
Ja, das habe ich verstanden.
Woran wurde diese Operation erfolgt?
Vor sieben Jahren.
Sind bei Ihnen andere Vorerkrankungen bekannt außer dieser Erwärmung?
Ja, ich habe sie auch schon vorgenommen.
Als Kind wurde ich am Blindarm operiert, da war ich glaube ich elf Jahre alt.
Mit elf Jahren?
Ja.
Denen zum Blachtoperationen gab es Komplikationen?
Nein.
Auch Galumblasen entfernen?
Nein, das war alles gut, alles gut verlaufen.
Herr Bonneman, hatten Sie einen Unfallerleden bisher?
Nein, ich hatte keinen Unfall.
Also nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein, außer Timotrol zweimal täglich.
Also ich nehme einmal Augentropfen, Timotol, und dann nehme ich noch ein Zettel anschauen, Visoprolol.
Visoprolol, wie viel Migran?
5 steht dahinter, nehme ich 2 am Tag.
Morgenstabend?
Eine morgens eine Abend, da nehme ich noch HCT heißt das, HCT.
Wie viel Migran?
25.
Wie oft nehmen Sie?
Eine Tablette morgens.
Und ich nehme noch Candidatan 16 steht dahinter.
Candidatan 16 Migran.
Wie viele Migran?
Eine Tablette morgens und eine halbe Abend.
Eine halbe Abend, kann der Sattan sagen.
Gegen erhörte Boulevard, was nehmen Sie?
Ja, da nehme ich auch noch Mittel, das heißt Simvastatin.
Wie viel Migran nehmen Sie?
20 steht dahinter, 20, nehme ich eine pro Tag.
Abends nehmen Sie?
Eine Tablette abends.
Wie haben Sie andere Medikamente?
Eine Medikamente sonst?
Da haben wir vor ungefähr 1,5 Stunden, weil die Kopfschmerzen so stark waren,
zwei Tabletten Paracetamol genommen.
Aber ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass die irgendeine Wirkung haben.
Die Einnahme von 2 Tablet Paracetamol haben die Schmerzen nicht gelindert?
Nein.
Wie viele Migran haben Sie eingenommen?
Ich habe noch für Erwachsene Stande Tablette für Erwachsene.
Ich habe noch für Paracetamol für Erwachsene standen.
Meinen Sie 1000-Miligramme oder 400-Miligramme?
Kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Dann frage ich Ihren Haushalt.
Können Sie bitte den Namen der Sassatz sagen?
Das ist Dr. Schulze.
Wie lautet die Telefonnummer der Sassatz?
872923.
Danke schön, Herr Bonemann.
Herr Bonemann, Sie sind schon vollständig gegen alle Kinderkrankheiten
und Covid-19-Games.
Ich werde immer von Betriebsarzt,
dann wird mein Impfpass angeschaut und manche auch vom Hausarzt.
Und die sagen im Augenblick brauche ich jetzt keine Impfung im Herbst,
jetzt wieder eine Grippeimpfung und eine Covid-Impfung.
Das ist aber erst geplant für Ende Oktober.
Für Noah Grippe und Covid-19.
Das ist der erste Impfungsverband.
Ich habe noch keine Impfung im Herbst.
Aber die anderen Kinderkrankheiten, dagegen sind Sie geimpft?
Es ist alles in Ordnung.
Reagieren Sie allergisch auf Polengräse, Haustoff oder Tiara?
Das ist mir nicht bekannt, habe ich bisher nie Probleme gehabt.
Aber Sie allergiegegenbestimmte Medikamente oder Kontrastmittel?
Nein.
Mit der Kontraktätigkeit rufen bei Ihnen Noah durch die Kinderkrankheiten
oder rufen bei Ihnen Noah durch?
Nein, da hatte ich immer mal Blähungen und Bauchschmerzen.
Das war nicht so gut.
Aber seitdem ich das weiß, richte ich meine Ernährung danach ein.
Und damit geht es mir gut.
Rauchen Sie Herr Bonnermann?
Ja, ich rauche.
Seit ungefähr 30 Jahren?
35 Jahre.
Ich habe nur für eine Schachter-Zigaretten-Protakt.
Eine Schachter-Zigaretten-Protakt?
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Sehr unregelmäßig.
Aufgrund meines Berufes kann ich mir das gar nicht erlauben.
Was trinken Sie?
Herr Bonnermann?
Wenn, dann trinke ich mal ein Glas Bier.
Aber das ist vielleicht einmal pro Woche oder alle zwei Wochen.
Das verstehe ich.
Herr Bonnermann, mitnehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich?
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein.
Oder hatten Sie schon mal Kontakt mit den Drogen?
Was sind Sie von Bezug, Herr Bonnermann?
Ich bin Straßenbahnfahrer.
Straßenbahnfahrer.
Mhm.
Sind Sie feieradet?
Ja, ohne mit meiner Frau zusammen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, drei Kinder.
Die sind, weil ich das weiß, gesund.
Die leben aber nicht mehr in dieser Stadt.
Die wohnen woanders.
Aber wir haben guten Kontakt.
Ich denke, sie sind gesund.
Aber ja, Ihre Kinder wohnen mit Ihnen nicht.
Aber sie sind gesund.
Ohne in anderen Städten?
Andere Städte.
Danke schön.
Deine Seite ist abgelaufen.
Deswegen, unsere Kollegen noch etwas zu sagen.
Ich trage vielleicht auch ganz kurz etwas zur Familienanalyse.
Ja, andere Kollegen möchte diese.
Okay.
Wir haben jetzt die Zeit, sich etwas zu bereiten.
Denken Sie an die Umsetzung der Medi-Patientensprache in die Fachbegriffe.
Die Übelkeit, Seestörungen, Verbrechen und so weiter.
Ich habe noch etwas zu sagen.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Familienanalyse und Sozialanalyse.
Ja, Familienanalyse.
Der Vater ist 87 Jahre alt.
Der Vater hat hohen Blutdruck.
Und hat eine Herzkranzgefäßerkrankung.
Und hat vor fünf Jahren, hat er zwei,
war in der Katheter und so,
zwei Röhrchen in die Herzkranzgefäße bekommen.
Die Mutter ist 85 Jahre alt.
Die hat eine schwere, gründliche Ponchitis.
Und ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Er ist 58 Jahre alt.
Der hat auch hohen Blutdruck.
Er hat eine Herzkranzgefäße.
Ja, ein Leben mit der Frau zusammen.
Und drei Kinder.
Und um Verträglichkeit haben wir gefragt?
Ja, ich habe vorstatt nur Milch zu können.
Alles.
Okay.
Gibt es bestimmte Ausschüsse für die Schmerzen?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Hallo.
Gibt es noch Fragen von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen?
Hören Sie mich?
Einstündigung.
Ja.
Gibt es bestimmte Ausschüsse für die Schmerzen?
Diese Frage fällt.
Ich kann mich nicht erklären, die Schmerzen.
Die kamen ja ziemlich plötzlich.
Und ich kenne keinen Auslöse.
Ich habe mich nicht besonders angestrengt.
Oder ich hatte keinen Stress.
Ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Ich sehe es keinen.
Ich denke, alle Fragen sind gestärkt.
Geschwindigkeit, Probleme gibt es oder gefragt?
Oder nicht?
Ich fühle mich insgesamt etwas verlangsamt.
Durch den Kopfschmerz, durch den Schwindel.
Ich bin dann unsicher.
Deswegen möchte ich gar nicht gehen.
Ich habe Angst, dass ich hinfalle.
Ich bleibe lieber sitzen.
Und halte so zusammen meinen Kopf.
weil der Kopf, wie wenn er auseinanderbeersten will.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, Vertigo, wie sieht aus Vertigo?
Wie schwangschwindel?
Ich drehe, wie ein Karussell.
Wie ein Karussell.
Diese Fragen bestimmt sehr wichtig.
Ja.
Karussell.
Parfisch, Fragen, Fragen.
Bitte schenatische.
Ja.
Kontrollieren Sie Ihre Blutdruck?
Ja, das ist ein heikles Thema.
Ich habe das im Anfang sehr regelmäßig kontrolliert.
Und in letzter Zeit bin ich da etwas nachlässig gewesen.
Meine Frau sagt immer zu mir, du musst einen Blutdruckkäufer kontrollieren.
Ich glaube, das letzte Mal habe ich ihn vor zwei Wochen kontrolliert.
Ja, aber?
Das war ungefähr 145 zu 90.
Vor zwei Wochen.
Ist das ein...
Danke schön.
Aber ich denke, müssen wir erst mal ein Metallparameter messen.
Ja, wichtig.
Das würde ich nicht dringend vorschlagen bei diesem Beschwerden, leicht zu anfangen.
Ja.
Zu Beginn sagen, zum Patienten sagen, ich möchte erst mal bei Ihnen,
damit ich mehr Informationen habe, den Blutdruck messen,
den Sauerstoff gehalten messen im Blut und vielleicht
sie an einen EKG anschließen, an einem Monitor.
Und dann setze ich die Befragung fort.
Ja, danke schön.
Ich würde mich in diesem Falle mit akuten Kopfschmerzen sehen.
Sehr schön.
Können wir erst mal ein Anfang machen?
Danke.
Ja.
Gut.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen, nämlich Herr Peter Bornemann.
Ja.
Er ist 61 Jahre alt, am 7. August 1963 geworden, 1,86 m groß und 95 kg schwer.
Der 61-jährige Patient stellte sich heute wegen seines 3 Stunden bestehender
flüstig abgetretener, stark ausgeprägter, diffusiver Zertalgie bei uns vor.
Laut dem Patientin seien die Schmerzen flüstig abgetrösten
und im Laufe der Zeit cinema geworden.
Er hatte für ihn auch ein leichtes Kopfschmerz.
Die Schmerzen des Zertalgie, die er als drückend unter Druck beschrieb,
hat in einem Intensität von 7 bis 8 von einem Skalapon 1 bis 10 und keine Ausstrahlung.
Als begleitet, stünd der benannte er, nause er, 2-malige MSI,
mit der schneimischen und gerblichen Konsistenz,
vertigo und so wie wiederum.
Der Patient hat auch das eher solche Kopfschmerzen einmal pro Monat gehabt.
Nicht so ist es nicht mehr so.
Solche Schmerzen einmal pro Monat, genauso stark wie jetzt?
Leichte Schmerzen, nicht so stark, aber leichter Schmerzen.
Aber die Charakter der Schmerzen sind gleich.
Der Patient hat immer mal wieder Kopfschmerzen,
aber der Patient hat gesagt, die sind mit diesen Kopfschmerzen nicht vergleichbar.
Ganz heftig.
Ich bin wegen der anderen Kopfschmerzen noch nie zu einem Arzt gegangen,
oder in einem Krankenhaus, aber heute ist der Kopfschmerz stark.
Das sind andere Kopfschmerzen als diese sonst.
Ich würde diese anderen Kopfschmerzen nicht zu sehr betonen.
Das ist ein Neben-Showplatz, glaube ich.
Diese Kopfschmerzen sind anders als die Arzt.
Nicht so intensiv?
Nicht so intensiv, das habe ich in diesem Intensität verstanden.
Wir werden uns über eine Nese ergab.
Eine zweimalige Nuktoli seit fünf Jahren.
Anfordererkrankungen seien seit 34 Jahren Glaubkomb,
seit zehn Jahren alterere Hypertonie und Hypercholesterinemi bekannt.
Vor sieben Jahren wurde eine Cholestistoktemie laproskopisch durchgeführt.
Von Kind auf sei er mit elf Jahren,
habe er sich eine Appendoktemie unterzogen
und bei Patientem sei eine Prostatahiparplasie bekannt.
Die Operationen seien komplikationslos zu verlaufen.
Er verwendet die Tumoptol-Augung,
zwei Mal täglich auf jedes Auge.
Er hat eine Tablete mit 25 mg,
eine Tablete mit 16 mg,
eine halbe Tablete mit 20 mg,
eine Tablete mit 1 mg.
Er ist vor allem gegen Kinderkrankheiten und Covid-19 geimpft.
Er hat eine Laktose-Intoleranz,
der Methodismus Abdominalenschmerz in Herf war.
Er saugt seit 35 Jahren,
eine Schachtelsigarette intäglich
und trinkt gelegenlich 1-Glas Bier,
ungefähr einmal pro Woche.
Er sei Straßenbahner,
hat drei gesunde Kinder
und wohnt mit seiner Frau zusammen.
Der Vater des Patienten
sei 87 Jahre alt,
leider an Arterelle Vipatoni und Kaheka.
Vor fünf Jahren sei beim Vater des Patienten
eine PTCA mit Anlage der zwei Stands durchgeführt worden.
Die Mutter des Patienten sei 85 Jahre alt
und sei an Asmobronchialen erkrankt.
Was ist das mit Asmobronchialen?
Asmobronchialen ist wahrscheinlich eine COPD.
Ich bin ja nicht sicher.
Die Mutter des Patienten sei 85 Jahre alt
und sei an COPD erkrankt.
Der Patient hat einen Bruder,
der an Arterelle Vipatoni leidet.
Haben Sie die Vitalparameter kontrolliert?
Vitalparameter, während der körperliche Untersuchung
werde ich die Vitalparameter kontrollieren.
Am Anfang der körperlichen Untersuchung
werde ich auf jeden Fall die Vitalparameter kontrollieren.
Ich würde Ihnen raten, dass Sie das gleich zuerst machen.
Wenn ein Patient mit solchen Beschwerden kommt,
starke Kopfschmerzen, die er noch nie hatte,
Schmerzgrad 7 bis 8, der Patient hat erbrochen,
ihm ist übel, dann würde ich allererstes im Patient sagen,
ich möchte jetzt zunächst einige kleine Untersuchungen bei Ihnen machen,
die mir aber wichtige Informationen bringen können.
Jetzt haben Sie die Vitalparameter gleich abgenommen
und der Patient hat einen Blutdruck von 240 bis 130.
Wenn Sie damit warten und erst die körperliche Untersuchung abwarten,
verschenken Sie vielleicht Zeit.
Es kann zu Komplikation führen.
Deswegen macht es Sinn,
weil so ein Bild wie bei akuten Turrachschmerzen,
oder Dispil, die erst die Vitalparameter zu kontrollieren,
wenn der Patient nicht mit dem Rettungswagen,
mit dem Krankenwagen kommt, wo das oft schon gemacht wird.
Aber dieser Patient ist privat gekommen,
erst vom Nachbarn gebracht worden.
Da sind diese Untersuchungen nicht gelaufen.
Also richtig ist, Vitalparameter lieber zu Anfang machen.
Das beruhigt Sie als Arzt,
das beruhigt den Patienten
und es macht einen guten Eindruck in der Prüfung.
Ja, das ist wichtig.
Also hier das Aufnahmegespräch unterbrechen?
Ja, ja, ja.
Wie meine?
Das weiß ich auch von anderen Prüfungen,
von anderen Kollegen.
Sie dürfen sagen, hier möchte ich die Befragung
oder Anamneseerhebung unterbrechen
und die erste Vitalparameter messen.
Und dann kann ich mit diesen Informationen fortfahren.
Wenn der Blutdruck jetzt nur leicht erhöht ist,
okay, aber dieser Blutdruck bei 240 zu 130,
da sprechen wir ja schon von einer Hypertonenkrise.
Und das könnte diese starken Kopfschmerzen ja auch erklären.
Unter anderem.
Diese ist ein Stimulation,
aber müssen wir ein Benik realistisch sein?
Ja, das würde ich immer machen.
Es macht Ihnen keinen Prüfer da einen Vorwurf,
sondern im Gegenteil, ich würde als Oberarzt fragen,
warum haben Sie nicht die Vitalparameter konprobiert?
Das wäre meine Frage an Sie dann.
Und wenn Sie das vorher gerade machen,
dann sind Sie da sehr gut, sehr außen vor.
Da sind Sie nicht angreifbar.
Aber ich glaube, diese Vitalparameter-Kontrolle
ist nicht recht.
Wir sollten auch, wenn wir dieses Anamäsegespräch unterbrechen,
wir sollten auch ein Set der Untersuchung spüren.
Also Sie können Folgendes machen in der Untersuchung.
Sie können jetzt kurz sagen,
ich unterbreche jetzt die Anamäse,
messe die Vitalparameter,
das müssen Sie jetzt ja nicht drei Minuten machen,
dass Sie gar nicht nur kurz sagen, dass Sie das tun würden.
Und dann sagen Sie, hiermit setze ich jetzt die Anamäse fort.
Das ist eine Sache, das zu benennen,
ist eine Sache von zehn Sekunden.
Ich würde es mir raten,
es kann nur ein Vorteil sein für Sie.
Dies ist ein, glaube ich,
ein internistisch neurologischer Notfall,
wie es passiert.
Und da sollten Sie so, würde ich ruhig so reagieren.
Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtdiagnose jetzt?
Ich habe ja schon fast alles gesagt.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt.
Ja, ich hier von einer hemorragischen Insel aus zuerst,
dann natürlich wegen dieser Voraikrankungen,
Voraikrankungen arteriologisch,
würde ich auch eine Pärternisive Krise als Verdachtdiagnose sagen.
Ein hemorragischer Insult hat denn der hemorragische Insult
wesentliche neurologische Symptome bei den Patienten,
außer Schwindel und Erbrechen oder so?
Ja, natürlich.
Deswegen habe ich danach gefragt, ob der Patient,
also Hypostesi, Parestesi, oder Hemiparesis.
Also insofern wäre für mich der Insult,
als Diagnose sage ich jetzt mal, nicht unbedingt erst rammig.
Ja.
Deswegen messen Sie zuerst den Blutdruck
und wenn Sie so einen hohen Blutdruck haben bei den Patienten,
dann kann das natürlich schnell in einen Insult münden.
Aber eine supererkonditionelle Hemorragie sein.
Nein, nein, nicht Hemorragie.
Hypertensiv, Hypertensivkrise, das reicht.
Also bei der Entschuldigung.
Ich bin der Lobbe, deswegen.
Bei der Diagnose.
Ich sage mal so, bei der Diagnose würde ich
auch an eine superarztneutral Blut umdenken.
Ja.
Aber wir reden jetzt nicht ums fachliche,
sondern mir geht es noch darum, dass Sie in der.
Ja, erste, meine Verdacht,
in erstens Hypertensivkrise,
dann kommt natürlich supererkonditionelle Hemorragie.
Auf alle Fälle, ja.
Ich, ich, aus der Parenziadion, natürlich kommen eine.
Ich würde sagen, erst mal Hypertensivkrise,
Sveiteglockonkrise.
Ja, aber warum?
Ich muss das glaube ich kaum nicht vergessen.
Ja, glaube ich kaum.
Aber ich denke mir erst mal nochmal,
Sie haben, finde ich, das supergut gemacht.
Mit Ihrer Befragung.
Sie sind etwas zu lange verblieben bei der Kopfschmerzgeschichte,
wo der Patient sagt, ich habe mal alle paar Wochen etwas Kopfschmerzen.
Da haben Sie sehr viel Zeit verbracht, das zu befragen.
Ich habe dann als Patient gesagt, das sind Kopfschmerzen,
die sind für mich aber nicht von Belangen.
Damit kann ich arbeiten, ich nehme keine Tabletten,
wer dagegen keine Schmerz tabletten.
Dieser Kopfschmerz, den ich heute habe,
der ist außergewöhnlich, der war noch nie.
Das ist für mich ein Einvernügend Kopfschmerz.
Deswegen komme ich jetzt in die Ambulanz,
damit mir geholfen wird, so macht.
Aber Sie haben, denke ich, die Befragung sehr gut gemacht.
Und Sie haben auch die Vorstellung, finde ich, sehr gut gemacht.
Auch sprachberig und vom Satzbau und die Begriffe gebracht.
Alles gut.
Find ich sehr gut.
Also Sie würden von mir eine sehr gute Note kriegen.
Das Einzige, was ich eben anmerken würde oder Ihnen raten würde,
erheben Sie bei so einem Patienten zuerst die Vitalbarkeit.
Oder sagen Sie das zumindest in der Prüfung.
Weil dann sagt der Prüfer, ah, der will sich absichern,
der will wissen, wie ist der Blutdruck bei einem Kopfschmerzpatienten
und so weiter.
Das, denke ich, ist sinnvoll.
Damit ist für Sie kein Nachtrag.
Sondern es kann nur ein Vorteil sein.
Und Sie haben das gut benannt.
Sie haben die Medikamente gut wiedergegeben, die Dosierung gut wiedergegeben.
Die einzelnen Diagnosen bin ich voll mit einverstanden.
Das ist gut.
Danke.
So ist das.
Wann haben Sie denn Ihre Prüfung?